[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine handball le club de
plaisir des clés rate le coche dans le
championnat de nationale 3 les illinois
se sont inclinés face à puteaux dans un
match électrique le résumé dans ce
magazine cyclisme 20 mois après le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines a accueilli une compétition
sportive dans son enceinte de septième
grand prix de vélizy a regroupé 150
sportifs reportage à suivre gymnastique
coup de projecteur aujourd'hui sur la
gemme elancourt maurepas le club fait
partie des meilleurs clubs d'île de
france dans cette discipline
ce sera notre module a découverte
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
mais avant de développer ce titre on va
parler un football on connaît désormais
l'adversaire de versailles pour les 32e
de finale de la coupe de france les
versailles se déplaceront sur le terrain
de l'us sarre-union un club alsacien qui
évolue en nationale 3 une belle occasion
à saisir pour les joueurs de la cité
royale qui joue une division plus haut
en nationale 2 la rencontre sera à
suivre le samedi 18 décembre à 13h45 sur
les chaînes du groupe eurosport rome on
continue par du handball ont joué ce
week-end dans le championnat de
nationale 3 plaisir les clés recevait le
club depuis tôt à l'occasion de la 10e
journée malgré une belle prestation des
yvelinois n'ont pas réussi à s'imposer
le résumé du match
un match électrique avec des
rebondissements les spectateurs du
gymnase nicholas leur souviendront
longtemps de cette rencontre entre
plaisir des clés plus tôt après une
première période équilibrée aucune des
deux équipes n'arrive à se détacher au
score les yvelinois arrive à recoller
juste avant la pause à la dernière
seconde sur ce tir 13 partout après 30
minutes les joueurs répondent présents
enfin du temps
mettre de l'envié de l'agressivité et de
la lucidité en attaque on finit par 13
13 à la mi temps c'est un vrai match de
handball c'est un plaisir de jeu ce
genre de match c'est plaisant ça met du
contact ça joue au ballon il ya des
années gardien voilà c'est c'est un bon
match au retour des vestiaires plaisir
les qui accélère et creuse l'écart les
deux minutes s'accumulent du côté de
puteaux avec un avantage de trois buts
on pense locaux à l'abri mais le match
bascule en milieu de seconde période les
joueurs des hauts-de-seine profitent des
pertes de balle reviennent au score et
passe devant plaisir les clés ne
reviendra pas 29 à 26 à la chaussée et
ses grosses déceptions
parce que
photo c'est un concurrent direct là pour
prendre maintien ni pour la montée mais
voilà il ya neuf équipes qui se tiennent
en trois ou quatre points et si on
gagnait aujourd'hui on passait devant
eux
pendant 40 minutes ont fait quasiment
jeu égal voire supérieur et
voilà sur les vingt dernières minutes on
déjoue complètement on perd trop de
ballons au classement plaisir les clés
ne vienne du championnat de nationale 3
prochaine rencontre ce samedi 11
décembre sur le terrain du 7e morlaix
on va continuer à parler de handball et
des autres résultats sportifs du
week-end dans les yvelines avec bixente
mérian senti stéphane qui nous a rejoint
sur ce plateau bonsoir bixente par
michael alors va donc parler handball
oui on vient justement d'aborder la
défaite de plaisir contre plutôt oui
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir mickaël
qu'un autre club yvelinois se trouve
dans cette même division 2 nationale 3
oui je crois exactement où ils le
vésinet carrière a également perdu sur
son parquet 24 à 30 contre loudéac le
hsbc et 6e donc un peu de vent plaisir
les clés au classement qui est 9e on
continue par du football comme en coupe
de france versailles continue aussi sa
petite route en nationale 2 toujours
aussi solide défensivement les
versailles et s'impose sur la plus
petite des marges 1 0 à la maison contre
saint-malo il reste dauphin de la
division derrière l'équipe réserve de
lorient c'est un peu plus compliqué pour
poissy en revanche avec une défaite chez
les voltigeurs de châteaubriant 2 1
voici l'état la huitième marche au
classement prochaine journée ce week-end
vers ça ira l'ira à plabennec voici
recevra vannes on descend d'une division
bixente en serons en nationale 3 si vous
le voulez bien une division en effet
michael dominée par la réserve du paris
saint germain et le racing club de
france c'était ce week-end la 9e journée
et menthe se relance un peu au
classement victor accrochés 3 buts à 2
contre drancy des concurrents directs au
maintien l'aimanté se donne donc un peu
d'air et son neuvième au classement à
quatre longueurs des derniers les
mureaux qui ont fait match nul 2 2 face
à meaux alors on va parler main tendue
du ballon d'or c'est bien c'est
exactement s'éloigne un peu des
résultats du week-end mais c'est tout
comme regardez cette petite photo de
messi qui pose avec sa famille et ses
sept ballons dans alors c'est vrai que
le joueur du paris saint germain à bord
fièrement on le voit sur ces images ces
sept ballons d'or dont le dernier obtenu
lundi lundi dernier j'attends une petite
photo de famille et une petite photo
tout seul aussi allongé au côté de ses
trophées
gagner un ballon d'or presque une
routine pour la star argentine du psg
qui était accompagnée quand même de
plusieurs de ses coéquipiers à la
cérémonie de france football trois
parisiens étaient dans le top 10 donc
qu'il y en ai ma paie également et jean
louis jean denat roma qui ont terminé
respectivement 9e et 10e et lui
n'étaient pas à la cérémonie mais
termine un peu plus loin derrière le
brésilien neymar se classe 16e petit
regret pour certains supporters
l'absence de leur capitaine marquinhos
du top 30 et un autre m bape ait un qui
a fait l'actualité en fin de semaine
dernière exactement celui qui a inspiré
qu'il y en ait mbappé pas sur son jeu
michael mais sur sa célébration c'est
bien qu'ils étaient nés mbappé il faut
croire qu'en contrepartie le petit ethan
a hérité d'une partie du talent de son
grand frère le jeune joueur arabe qui
avait signé l'été dernier au psg et
maintenant c'est au tour de sa première
sélection en équipe de france il
rejoindra les u16 pour un stage de
quatre jours qui a débuté aujourd'hui et
qui terminera le 9 décembre peut-être
verra-t-on un jour miquel et les deux
frères sur le même terrain d'autant que
et anne n'est pas du tout dans le même
registre c'est plutôt un milieu de
terrain qui sembleraient
dont le définit comme ça plutôt défensif
plutôt défensif et fort par sa vision de
jeu et sa polyvalence bon peut-être
qu'on les verra un jour ensemble sur les
terrains pourquoi pas en équipe de
france alors on revient dans le sport
amateur avec du rugby les lie 8e journée
en poule 1 de fédérale 3 vous savez la
division dominé par les clubs imminent
n'ont pas souvent c'est un peu notre
petite fierté c'est les premiers sons
versailles ils conservent leur
invincibilité sept matches sept
victoires cette fois c'est caen qui en a
fait les frais le score 24 à 17 ans
dauphin du verre c'est le mlsgp maisons
laffitte a même pris le bonus offensif
contre petit couronne 31 points inscrits
pour 6 encaissés un bilan donc de cinq
victoires et deux défaites et juste
derrière ou une complète le podium avec
aussi une victoire bonifiée 43 à 23 sur
la pelouse de cergy-pontoise prochaine
journée ce week-end michael versailles
recevra justement cergy lemay est le mls
gp recevra caen et pas de match pour
couilles trois clubs un heavy loi sur le
podium alors on termine par du basket
mais j'aime cette sixième journée de
nationale 3 avec l'un des favoris de la
division trappe qui a perdu les
trappistes se sont fait surprendre par
un club pourtant en bas de tableau dans
la division bezons défaite 60 à 57 enfin
dernier de la division marly-le-roi
s'impose au mans 69 64 et c'est un petit
événement puisque c'est la première
victoire des marlins choix qui reste
malgré tout dernier du classement mais
qui se rapproche du milieu de tableau
car devant se trouve un petit troupeau
qui à seulement deux longueurs d'avancé
quand bezons barjouville airways merci à
bixente pour toutes ces précisions vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau tour d'horizon des résultats
sportifs du week-end dans les yvelines
je vous attends lundi prochain michel
lesire alors maintenant parler un
cyclisme ont pensé qu'il serait annulée
vu le contexte sanitaire il a finalement
bien eu lieu ce dimanche 5 décembre
après 20 mois sans événement sportif le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueilli le
grand prix de vélizy un rendez vous qui
a réuni 150 sportifs heureux de
retrouver le chemin de la compétition
reportage
la préparation la concentration
l'effort
l'adrénaline tous les ingrédients d'une
compétition sportive était de retour au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vraiment après
l'organisation de la dernière course
cycliste de la structure le septième
grand prix de vélizy s'est déroulée ce
dimanche 5 décembre à moi c'est très
long et en plus on sent qu il y a une
des mobilisations des bénévoles des
équipes d'organisation donc il faut
remettre tout ça en ordre de marche il
faut re motiver donc tout toutes les
équipes donc on y arriver et j'espère
que l'on va continuer voilà sur cette
lancée pour continuer sur cette lancée
organiser deux nouvelles courses
vélodrome nationale est suspendu à une
décision celle de retransformer ou non
leurs centrales en méga centres de
vaccination comme cela l'a été de mars à
fin octobre aujourd'hui les injections
se font dans les coursives de la
structure on travaille en osmose avec
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour trouver les solutions qui
conviennent à tous
et qui permettent de maintenir
voilà la vaccination parce que ça on
comprend que c'est important et il faut
le faire mais tout en conservant les
activités habituelles du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
si l'avenir est incertain pour les
rendez vous sportifs dans la structure
les 150 coureurs présents ce jour là
n'ont pas boudé leur plaisir ça fait
forcément du bien de refaire des mages
de vitesse des sprints ouais j'attendais
ça
avec impatience donc à reprendre par une
conviction à domicile ça fait toujours
du bien c'est quand même cool de pouvoir
retrouver des marques sur la compétition
pouvoir retrouver un quelques amis
puissent se confronter pour voir où on
en est au niveau tant au niveau
performance ça permet aussi de mieux
progresser les prochaines manifestations
cyclistes sont pour le moment programmé
en janvier février
si la situation sanitaire le permet
du golfe à présent et un jeune golfeur à
suivre il a débuté à seulement deux ans
cette discipline georgette aujourd'hui à
4 ans le plus jeune a licencié du golfe
isabella de plaisir muni de son club x s
il vient taper la balle blanche tous les
dimanches avec sa famille son portrait
par bixente mérian santisteva qu'est-ce
qui t'apprend à jouer au golf
a pas une passion de père en fils à 4
ans seulement georges est le plus jeune
licencié du golfe isabella de plaisir
une histoire avec les clubs qui a débuté
il ya presque deux ans ça faisait un
enfin un peu moins d'un an et six mois
qu'il avait démarré et donc il y avait
cette période de qu'ovide où on était
tous à la maison et là bas pendant les
après midi lorsqu'on était enfermé bas
j'ai sorti un club est vraiment j'ai
remarqué que george a été très attiré il
tapait avec moi pratiquement tous les
midis incident et des balles pour faire
des petites approche pour françois son
père georges a déjà les qualités pour
faire de lui un futur bon golfeur et ce
même en temps de plus je trouve qu'il
est il reste très concentré parce qu'ils
apprécient vraiment ça ils sont
objectifs et quand il tape une balle
c'est nous montrer qu' il a réussi donc
les très cher lorsqu'il a réussi à taper
la balle et après vraiment essayé de la
rentrée jusque dans le trou et il reste
très patient donc ça s'est vraiment bien
et c'est aussi autre chose c'est que
quand il rate un coup il arrive à se
reconcentrer et dire c'est pas grave je
vais réessayer une deuxième fois tous
les dimanches l'apprenti golfeur vient
sur le domaine de plaisir soit pour
jouer avec sa famille soit pour
renforcer ses bases landes un cours de
45 minutes georges a été a été licencié
l'année de ses deux ans a au cours de sa
deuxième année là il a démarré à deux
ans et demi et et on a grand plaisir à
le compter parmi nos effectifs c'est
effectivement notre plus jeune pousse et
ça prouve à tout le monde qu'il n'ya pas
ya vraiment pas de limite pour que pour
commencer le goal
contrairement à d'autres enfants du club
il a il a moins déjà besoin de ses
parents pour aller tout de suite en
cours en fait il est il espère motiver
il pas trop timide georges a déjà passé
son premier drapeau en cours et
lorsqu'on lui demande il se voit
poursuivre sa passion pour toute la vie
on passe maintenant notre coup de
projecteur de la semaine aujourd'hui tv
78 est allé du côté de la gemme
elancourt mort pas une structure qui
pratiquent la gymnastique à haut niveau
regardez aujourd'hui nous partons la
découverte de la jem l'un des meilleurs
clubs de gymnastique de france
[Musique]
pour nous parler de l'histoire de ce
club morgan goulard est à mes côtés
c'est la présidente du club alors morgan
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter
l'historique de ce club
alors le club a été créé en 1977
voilà donc on a un peu plus de quarante
ans maintenant il a évolué au fil des
années je suis la présidente du club
seulement depuis à peu près de deux ans
quelque chose comme ça voilà on a
performer le plus possible on a eu
la dernièrement du coup on est en
division nationale une chez les filles
et on avait une équipe nationale chez
les garçons on essaie d'évoluer au fil
des années et de garder le niveau est de
garder la performance et de monter de
nouveaux projets année après année est
ce qu'on peut dire que la gemme fait
partie du paysage maintenant français
adage gymnastique
je pense je pense que on essaye de rayon
en tout cas on essaye c'est l'idée après
voilà les deux dernières années était un
peu compliqué mais voilà on essaye de
garder un niveau national de garder une
équipe en division nationale une on
essaie de remonter une section garçons à
un niveau national donc voilà on essaye
de rayonner en tout cas sur les
compétitions nationales et donc de
rester dans le paysage français de la
gymnastique le plus possible on le voit
il ya beaucoup de monde qui travaillent
autour de nous c'est un petit peu ça
aussi le secret de la réussite du club
oui c'est c'est c'est aussi d'accueillir
le maximum d'adhérents possible de faire
découvrir la gymnastique un maximum
d'enfants de leur faire aimer de les
fidéliser aussi donc voilà le plus
d'adhérents on a plus on est on est
satisfait de la saison voilà encore une
fois cette année c'est assez une reprise
donc on essaie de retrouver
les adhérents qu'on avait avant de
refiler lisez tout le monde donner goût
à la gymnastique et au sport aussi parce
que ces derniers ont été compliquées
c'est en tout cas c'est l'idée combien
de licenciés au total six au club alors
en avant qu'on vit on avec 488 6 pendant
qu vide on était descendu à 380 et là on
est remonté à un petit peu plus de 2 400
donc on doit être à 420 quelque chose
comme ça et si on regarde autour de nous
il ya des filles mais aussi des garçons
on dit souvent que c'est la gymnastique
c'est un sport de films ya beaucoup de
garçons oui il ya beaucoup de gars on
les ya beaucoup plus de filles que de
garçons au club c'est vrai mais mais la
gymnastique c'est un sport et masculin
et féminin c'est vrai que la gymnastique
féminine est un peu plus médiatisé que
la jeunesse masculine mais il ya aussi
des très bons résultats français en
gymnastique masculine donc donc voila
nous on ne lâche pas la section
masculine et l'idée c'est d'avoir les
deux sections qui cohabitent et qui
arrive à performer le plus possible
voilà on a moins d'adhérents masculin on
essayait de remonter petit à petit les
nouvelles générations des garçons voilà
on verra dans quelques années
il ya aussi beaucoup de jeunes qui
intègrent le club c'est un petit peu la
spécificité de gymnastique on commence
très tôt en général on peut commencer la
gymnastique à 15 mois donc c'est vrai
que c'est très tôt on vient avec papa et
maman ou tata tente enfin peu importe
avec un adulte de la famille au cours de
baby gym à partir de 15 mois et puis
après on suit cursus d éveil d'après de
la gymnastique loisir et éventuellement
de la compétition mais en effet c'est un
sport on commence très tôt la baby gym
c'est idéal pour les repères dans
l'espace la coordination
l'appréhension de l'arrière de la
hauteur voilà c'est vraiment un sport
qu'on peut commencer très jeune pour
commencer à avoir des sensations et
appréhender son corps et ses repères
dans l'espace et le club organise
également des compétitions et
le club a notamment réalisé récemment
une compétition vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines est-ce que
c'est dans l'adn du club et aussi de
proposer des grandes manifestations de
gymnastique alors oui on a organisé
alors tous les ans de toute façon on
organise une compétition
depuis des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années on essaie d'organiser au moins
une finalité régionale ou une demi
finale des championnats de france et
c'est vrai qu'en 2019 on a organisé les
championnats de france au vélodrome à
saint quentin donc c'était une super
expérience c'était vraiment incroyable
on a essayé de vraiment fédérer des
équipes les bénévoles on a eu des
bénévoles des clubs aux alentours pas
forcément que du club de la gemme on
allait un peu plus de 200 bénévoles on a
accueilli des équipes de la france
entière c'était les championnats de
france nationale a en équipe donc on
avait en plus dans nos équipes qui qui
concourait on avait la division
nationale une aussi des concours est
donc c'était c'était vraiment une super
expérience on a fait venir les scolaires
aussi qu'ont pu découvrir la gymnastique
et ça ça a vraiment aussi bas ça s'est
retrouvée sur les retours qu'on a eue
après l'événement sur les parents
essaient de me contacter pour avoir des
informations et c'est donc au nom je
pense que c'est vraiment ça fait partie
du club on a envie de se donner des
défis plus là on a un projet et
éventuellement pour 2023 on va attendre
de saint quentin en yvelines mais
j'espère j'espère s'est vidée en tout
cas si on peut se le permettre on
aimerait bien organisé un nouvel
événement vélodrome que ce soit
international on verra si on vise le
plus haut et ça permet d'attirer aussi
peut-être de nouveaux licenciés à votre
avis d'avoir plus de visibilité
ouais mais exactement comme je le disais
par exemple les championnats de france
comme on a eu les scolaires eh ben on a
touché une nouvelle cible qu'on touche
pas forcément à d'habitude et ben voilà
ça certains ont découvert un sport une
des sensations et sont revenus vers nous
après et était intéressé pour commencer
la jeunesse les grands projets pour le
club sur les prochaines années parce que
vous les avez en tête
les grands projets alors en termes
d'organisation l'événement 2023 c'est ce
que ce sera nationale ou internationale
on verra en fonction du soutien qu'on a
aussi et puis en termes de performances
sportives eric vous en parlera mieux que
moi mais c'est de maintenir un niveau de
performance comme on a aujourd'hui donc
de rester en division nationale une
c'est de fidéliser nos adhérents que ce
soit les loisirs ou les compétitions qui
reste dans le club qu'ils aiment le club
et qu'ils aiment la gymnastique voilà
c'est ça les projets principaux et puis
éventuellement voilà on est aussi en
train d'essayer de monter des sections
on a une section sportive au collège de
la clé saint pierre pour permettre
justement à ces gymnastes qui font de la
compétition et de la performance d'avoir
un bon aménagement au niveau des
horaires elle s'entraîne donc le
mercredi matin et mardi et jeudi
après-midi dans le cas de cette section
et donc nous on aimerait beaucoup
pouvoir monter cette section sportive
sur l'école primaire et sur le lycée
pour que ces jeunes filles du début de
leur carrière de performance elle puisse
allier l'école et la gymnastique dans de
bonnes conditions de du cp à la
terminale merci morgan on va maintenant
voir le coach
[Musique]
c'est vous qui supervise et un petit peu
tout ou ce club comment ça se passe
écoutez moi mon rôle c'est
administrativement de gérer tout ce qui
est planning détection des gymnastes
organisation secteur masculin et féminin
aussi bien en compétition qu'en loisir
et puis après j'ai un deuxième rôle plus
l'eau à dire technique dans
l'entraînement donc entraîner les
équipes premières l'équipe de dn1 et les
équipes derrière pour la relève le club
de l'ag mais plutôt dans la performance
ou le loisir finalement en fait on
essaye de faire on a deux grandes
traditions de loisirs on a commencé
comme ça c'est l'épreuve dps concret et
ferment 117 donc avec que des loisirs et
petit à petit on a réussi à rentrer dans
on va dire l'élite de la gymnastique
avec notre équipe de dn1 depuis
plusieurs années voire même en top 12
donc on essaye de maintenir ce niveau de
performance ce niveau d'exigence mais en
même temps de permettre à des gym de
groupes loisirs de s'épanouir comment on
fait pour garder ce niveau d'exigence
j'imagine que c'est le travail avant
tout on vous a vu tout à l'heure vous
étiez très minutieux sur sur les détails
c'est un petit peu ça la marque de
fabrique un du club on essaye on essaye
le détail c'est ce qui fait la
différence en fait le travail de base
c'est ce qui va permettre de construire
une gymnaste solide et qui va progresser
dans le temps si on va trop vite sur
certains points ont fait des raccourcis
bas on se rend compte que la chine elle
est bloquée et qu'elle ne peut plus
progresser donc au bout du compte elle
arrête la gym parce que ce qui est
intéressant c'est de progresser toujours
et de pouvoir performer donc on essaye
de faire attention dès le départ à cette
rigueur et comment on fait pour voir
pont pour analyser pour trouver cette
nouvelle pépite ici au club
c'est difficile je pense qu'on doit
passer aussi à côté de temps en temps
nous on essaie déjà de voir une gym qui
est dynamique qui est rebondissante qui
est explosive voilà qui courent partout
on préfère avoir une fille comme ça que
j ai posé dans son coin voilà déjà avoir
envie d'être là d'être heureuse d'être à
la salle c'est déjà une à la première
chose qu'on essaie de trouver chez une
gym et puis après c'est accepter le
travail accepter l'échec parce que
malheureusement on sait que avant de
réussir il faut rater et donc voilà
c'est un savant mélange de réussie des
chèques de travail de plaisir c'est
compliqué mais on y est c'est long et ça
y est ce que vous avez déjà la nouvelle
pépite du club ici je sais pas après
vous savez c'est c'est un engagement sur
une dizaine d'années minimum donc pour
savoir si dans dix ans elle sera
performante est ce qu'il y aura une
blessure est ce qu'il y aura un nouveau
confinement est ce qu'il y aura un
déménagement on sait pas mais
effectivement on commence à voir de 3,4
petit qui arrive derrière des petites
2015 ça peut paraître très très jeune
mais on qui ont des prédispositions qui
sont fortes qui sont heureuses d'être à
la salle qui viennent avec le sourire et
qui sont appliquées donc pour nous c'est
l'avenir du club le club préfère former
ses futurs élites ou les rapatriés de
dos de club vous cherchez également
d'autres dans d'autres clubs alors on ne
cherche pas s'est toujours refusé à
démarcher des autres clubs ça nous est
arrivé d'avoir des gym qui viennent
d'autres clubs mais celle de leur
volonté ou ne va pas
chercher à faire transférer comme on
peut voir en foot on ne sait pas du tout
notre volonté après c'est déjà arrivé
que des gym de très bon niveau viennent
parce qu'en fait quand on a une équipe
de dn1 c'est un peu on va dire un
aspirateur faire ça c'est les ligues
clubs alentour ont envie de match à ce
niveau là les gym qui n'ont pas
forcément un projet comme ça dans leur
club ou envie de venir donc on les
accueille bien volontiers mais on va pas
les chercher nous notre volonté c'est de
former voilà après si d'autres viennent
il ya pas de problème la porte n'est pas
fermée mais ça sera jamais notre volonté
d'aller débaucher les autres clubs le
but du jeu c'est de quais plus de gens
qui fassent de la gym c'est pas
d'appauvrir les clubs audois en jour
[Musique]
à mes côtés deux athlètes du club flavie
et hyaline bonsoir mes demoiselles alors
cyanide pourquoi tu vas choisi ce club
parce que mon frère et ma soeur ilisu se
sont fait inscrire ici et du coup bah
moi j'ai suivi leurs traces voilà et
parce que c'est un bon club j'avais un
club à côté de chez moi mais ne
permettait pas d'aller ossio dans les
compètes aussi loin alors je crois
savoir que tu habites à molette ça à 30
km à peu près d'ici et qu'est ce qui te
motive à venir tous tous les jours ici
ou presque pas parce que je sais que
c'est un bon club et que c'est là que je
vais progresser je peux aller loin je
peux aller jusqu'aux jusqu'à des
compétitions internationales
donc la distance n'était pas un frein
alors pour toi flavie du coup pourquoi
tu as choisi ce club c'est avant tout
parce que c'est un club familial oui
parce que c'est à côté de chez moi ma
mère l'inscrit si du coup bah j'ai
essayé ici et ça m'a beaucoup plu et du
combat depuis je continue à la gym à
elancourt maurepas est-ce que flavie tu
as le sentiment que ce club est
peut-être l'un des meilleurs de france
oui parce que depuis qu'on est là on a
beaucoup progressé et on est allés
jusqu'aux championnats de france on a eu
plusieurs médailles et depuis bas plus
les entraînements passe plus on
progresse et et voilà est ce que le club
a les infrastructures aussi pour faire
progresser on le voit autour de nous
beaucoup beaucoup de ta vie des époux de
partout est ce que le club a les
infrastructures pour vous faire
progresser oui oui a vraiment ce qu'il
faut et chaque année des nouveaux
éléments
arrivé au club et du coup ça me fait
encore plus progressé et voilà vous
passé commun de temps ici par semaine
les filles à peu près 18 heures 18
heures par semaine à peu près et on s'en
lasse pas non ça n'est ce pas flavie
même chose moi un peu moins mais non
plus on s'en lasse pas on s'en lasse pas
et quel est votre palmarès à toutes les
deux toits par exemple la vie on a fait
une première en championnat de france en
2015 nous ressemble et moi j'ai fait 3e
aux championnats de france il ya 4 5 ans
vous faites partie la même équipe depuis
toujours oui bah oui oui totalement et
vos objectifs à vous dans les prochaines
années c'est quoi à lasser de refaire
des compétitions parce qu'avec le coc
vide n'a pas eu l'occasion d'en faire ça
fait à peu près deux ans qu'on en a pas
fait et reprendre les compétitions se
qualifier pour les championnats de
france et et continuer à rester en dn1
mes objectifs la lie oui pareil vu qu'on
est dans la même équipe maintenir la dn1
puisque le plus longtemps possible et
revenir en force pour les compétitions
après ces deux ans de co lead on vous le
souhaite en tout cas bon courage à
toutes les deux
[Musique]
le club de la gemme compte 420 adhérents
cette année espère dépasser ce chiffre
dans les approches un mois et le club
veut remporter d'autres titres sur la
scène nationale c'est la fin de cette
émission merci l'avoir suivi à bientôt
sur tv 78
[Musique]